what taught you that that was a normal
way of like life well I didn't think it
was a normal way of life but I didn't
want a normal life you're a very clean
person just in general I'm neat I would
spending very a lot of effort to not
make a mess I wouldn't have to clean so
I would like eat over the sink the same
cup dude it works fine and then I had
all the animal pictures on the wall of
like and killing and attack positions
because like I was really hardcore at
the time like more than I am now and I
was just like I always want to be
reminded that I'm either the predator of
the prey for me it was like I didn't
want to work or whatever I was just like
everything around me was like keep going
I was very much in the like I have to
grind I have to work a lot